in a tube deep underground
archaeologists carefully remove the lid
from an
a stone sarcophagus
inside lie the mummified remains of an
Egyptian priest
hidden for the past two and a half
thousand years
oh my God
this is beautiful
closer inspection though the mummy isn't
What It Seems
no way
and the investigation takes a surprise
turn
there is something quite mind-blowing
forcing the team to question all that
it's found so far
I might belong but I would be very
surprised if there is no more surprises
in this conflict
[Music]
thank you
foreign
renowned egyptologist Dr Ramadan Hussein
and his team of archaeologists are
Excavating a remarkable new site
when I started archeology I never
thought I would be discovering something
on that magnitude
extensive 3D scams reveal a unique
ancient Egyptian funeral complex
from around 600 BC where the dead were
brought to be mummified and buried in an
assortment of Chambers deep underground
this tomb complex dates to the 26th
Dynasty and that's about 700 years after
Tutankhamun and about 600 years before
Cleopatra and the end of Egyptian
history as we knew it
this time period is interesting because
this is when Egypt had had a huge Renee
Source in religion and burial ideas so
this find is really a snapshot in time
and crucial to our understanding of
mummification
thank you
today Ramadan and his team are
investigating a pair of stone sarcophagi
[Music]
they lie in a small chamber almost 100
feet below the surface
we have two sealed sarcophagi
one in what we call anthropoid
sarcophagus it means it takes the human
form and another one that is a
rectangular sarcophagus
what makes them so special is that
unlike the other sarcophagi in this
complex they're both inscribed with text
once we discovered this writing we
understood how valuable this is so we
have put protective paper here
this is our means of communication with
the engines
the inscriptions are carved on one
sarcophagus and painted on the other
and they provide fascinating clues about
the people buried inside
foreign
for me it is a moment that I can read
the minds of these two persons to be
able to know what they wanted to convey
us what they wanted to tell us
the ancient Egyptians believed that
remembering the name of the deceased by
writing it down would lead to their
immortality
and the text on the caskets reveals a
pair of male names
China meat
and he put
but the text also contains another vital
piece of information their jobs
and interestingly they both match
so far from the tax material we have
collected we have two priests this is
shanimi
right behind me here is another priest
and his name is put
[Music]
while this is priceless information it
raises an important question
why are these two priests here
is it purely by chance that they share
the same tomb
or could they be in some way connected
that is pretty much the mystery
why do you have two priests right next
to one another this is a question to be
answered when we lift up this lid
[Applause]
to learn more about the two priests
Ramadan must open up the sarcophagi and
investigate their contents in forensic
detail
[Music]
led by their Foreman Amar the team is
starting with the rectangular
sarcophagus of chanamite
foreign
[Music]
the first task is to break open the
thick layer of mortar running around the
edge of the lid
intended as a seal to deter grave
robbers its presence can mean only one
thing
this sarcophagus is 2 600 years old and
it hasn't been touched since China meat
was buried inside it
I know this is a three-man job
so we'll see how successful this is
going to be
um
it is very intense moment for me what is
inside this circle
let me know
it seems to be working
hello
now the casket is part way open Ramadan
uses an inspection camera to take a
preliminary Peak
this is unbelievable
[Music]
what it reveals is like nothing else
from the complex ah
[Music]
glittering stuff
a 2 600 year old mummy
to toe in an elaborate beaded burial
shroud
amazingly still in one piece
beautiful beaded net
it is so elegant this is so beautiful
[Music]
not as pristine as you would see at the
museums but this is long Nami that will
carries the dust and aging of 2 600
years
this is remarkably decorated Mommy
this definitely stands out as one of the
most remarkable sarcophants that I've
ever opened
I have a job to bring the enemy back to
life
we want his story to be told
and I think
I'm going to tell the story of tiny meat
from now until I die
I have so much to do
beneath the ancient pyramids of Sakara
the task of opening China meets Stone
sarcophagus is well underway
[Music]
after glimpsing a beaded shroud lying on
just mummy
Project Director Ramadan is Keen to
learn more about this mysterious priest
I'm Lauren his team just lifted up the
lid
it's a difficult job it's a lot of Labor
a lot of sweat come on
come on
before we roll it out we need to make
sure that nothing will fall on this
beautiful mummy so we're spreading a
cloth underneath the lid
we're good to go
carved from solid Limestone weighs
almost 2 000 pounds
and the team will slide it out on steel
rollers
when you move film a large piece of
stone like this lid
you don't want this Stone to smash
somebody's bones uh that's first second
is not to damage and Destroy any object
inside the sarcophagus
so those are the two main concerns
safety of the living and also the safety
of the Dead
okay
now I think we're gonna have a full look
at the mummy of China meat
foreign
just unbelievable
[Music]
it is as if actually it was made
yesterday
beautiful
made from hundreds of glazed clay beads
China meets perfectly preserved burial
shroud was intended to protect him in
the afterlife
its quality and craftsmanship are a
clear sign that China meat was a wealthy
individual
this is the work of an artist that was
done 2 600 years ago and now we're
getting a first look at it a bit for a
bit
the caller is coming out is so beautiful
also beaded right here
[Music]
the head of the Mummy
it's still wrapped to see his eyes and
the nose and the eyebrows and even the
mouth drawn on this linen bandages
[Music]
this is one of the most beautiful
mummies
I have ever seen in my life
what is
so amazing it's the preservation of the
beaded net
and the necklace
after 2 600 years
[Music]
unbelievable
but now the question that is on my mind
who is this person to have deserved such
an elaborate burial
to shed light on why a priest like
chalamid was able to afford such
luxuries project consultant salima igram
has come to one of the most iconic sites
in all of Egypt
historic city of Luxor on the banks of
the River Nile
among the many nearby tombs is a vast
Mausoleum belonging to a priest called
pariamanopet
it was always in ancient Egypt good to
be a priest because of course religion
was of the utmost importance and also
you enter into this hierarchy of the
temples and the religion and so it's
sort of like a Brotherhood
[Music]
of the many Egyptian gods or goddesses
was a full-time job
but for an elite few like padayamanopan
it was a career that brought wealth and
status
one of the most striking things about
pariamanopan's tomb is the fact that it
is huge
it's the largest non-royal tomb in all
of laksa the workmanship is exquisite
and it's lavishly decorated and it would
originally have been painted and you can
still see some of the vestiges of paint
which means that he must have been one
of the richest and most influential men
when he died
almost every wall of this enormous
22-room tomb is covered in either
paintings or inscriptions
and they contain important information
about padayama no Pet's life including
how he was able to amass such wealth
priests were very important in Egyptian
society and periamanope here you can see
for his a priest elect a priest someone
who reads but he was also a royal scribe
he was known to the king he had was a
courtier and he like many other priests
had lots of jobs so priests weren't just
religious beings they were political
they were industrial some of them were
even in the military they really had
their fingers in all kinds of pies
and so you wind up with people who have
enormous wealth that they can amass from
a huge number of different sources
so could Chana meets elaborate burial be
a clue to the sort of life he led as a
priest
Ramadan is hoping to find some answers
in the painted text on his sarcophagus
now that it's protective covering is
being removed
foreign
tax is so valuable for every
archaeologist it is that joy to be able
to
read the minds of the Ancients what
we're reading here is
if we can draw any analogy a an
identification card of this person and
right here for example we see the name
of the deceased cha knee meat which
literally means
the little child of the cat the worship
of the cat among Egyptians was very very
common and
it was notably common among a segment of
the Egyptian society that is mostly
Libyan immigrant so the name China meat
could that be an indication that we're
dealing with a Libyan Descent of some
sort
Heritage isn't all that's contained in
the inscription
so working backwards we see some of his
Priestly titles here for example and we
could see that he is a priest of the
goddess and the Goddess Isis two of the
most important goddesses in the ancient
Egyptian Pantheon
then we continue to see more of his
Priestly titles
in other words just like the priest
Patia monopet China meat held more than
one position
[Music]
we're talking about somebody who had
evidently a long career as a priest this
must be somebody who accumulated a
certain kind of wealth
so what brought such a distinguished
priest here to Sakara
this burial chamber has already given us
a lot to think about
and how if at all is China meat
connected to yiput the other priest
buried in the chamber
[Music]
inside the priest's burial chamber
ramadan's team is preparing to remove
chanamit's mummy from the sarcophagus so
they can examine it for more clues
a little bit up little bit too wide as
there's a chance of damaging The Mummy
the Project's digital team is first
creating a perfect copy
using a technique called photogrammetry
[Music]
so first of all I took like thousands
pictures of this mummy and we can put
all these pictures and in a software and
then the computers figures out what we
have done with all the pictures and
creates out of all pictures of 3D model
and it's a complete new approach
understanding archaeological sites like
this especially when they're on the
ground
the 3D map of the Tomb complex now
contains China meets open sarcophagus
and the real beauty of this technique is
that it records each stage of the
excavation allowing the team to go back
and re-examine key details
like The Faded text on channel meets
sarcophagus
where Ramadan has spotted a mysterious
name
we're looking now at the titles of chani
meat connecting him to several gods and
goddesses from ancient Egypt very
prominent ones but it was so intriguing
here is that he's a priest of a goddess
a serpent goddess her name is newches
with this circle then a rectangular
below it then a bolt
and at the end he serpent
when I first saw the name a new chess I
had trouble reading it because we don't
see that name a lot
sounds really
very strange
while this latest Discovery is an
important development it now leaves
Ramadan with a new set of questions
who was this obscure serpent goddess
and why was a priest of some of the most
important deities in Egypt in her
service
in search of Clues project consultant
salima is once more in the city of Luxor
[Music]
thank you
we're here at Luxor Temple which is one
of the most important temples in this
area because it contains lists of gods
and goddesses and if we're in search of
a particular deity this would be the
place to go
among the many hieroglyphs covering the
temple walls is what's brought her here
a tiny but familiar looking inscription
and it's right up here where you've got
that Circle up there the crossing it
and beneath that there's a funny hook
and this lovely snake
one of the very few mentions of new
chayez to be found anywhere in Egypt
and in fact this is the first time her
name occurs ever
[Music]
What's significant is the inscriptions
location
inside a separate Chapel within the
Temple dedicated to one of the most
eminent of all Egyptian deities
the Great Goddess moot
moot was so important because she was
the consort of the god Amun King of the
Gods so basically she's queen of the
gods and mooch is also the great mother
goddess and in fact the word for mother
in Egyptian is Moot and she was in
charge of the fertility of the land the
people the herds and a great protector
of women
[Music]
so revered by the ancient Egyptians that
they depicted her in many different ways
as the mother of the Pharaoh
as a powerful ruler
even as a lioness
and so here in this Chapel we have moot
in all of her different guises and all
of her different aspects
and one of moot's other lesser-known
geysers was the serpent-like new chayez
here you see that nutrias is really just
an aspect of the Goddess mood and an
aspect in serpent form like you can see
from her name
she's not very significant it would seem
and they're only a handful of mentions
with this very elusive mythological
figure that we have throughout Egyptian
history now 600 years later at Sakara in
the Tomb of China meat it's a different
story because China meat is a priest of
the goddess nutrias and this means
suddenly newtius is an independent
entity suddenly she becomes somebody
[Music]
fully fledged goddess in her own right
and what's remarkable is that China meat
wasn't alone in worshiping this new
deity
in a small tomb next to the priest's
chamber Ramadan and his team have made
an extraordinary discovery
a mummy wearing a Priceless gilded
silver burial mask the first found in
Egypt for almost a century
one of the fascinating things about this
find is that the text on the coffin
reveals that its owner was a priest just
like China meat
and that he too worshiped the serpent
goddess new chayez
which means that new chayez must have
become a very significant goddess indeed
all of a sudden our conflicts here we
have two individuals they're connecting
themselves to the goddess nutrias being
Priests of this goddess
a revolution in what we know about this
goddess we're hoping for more
information about her
[Music]
thank you
in light of the discovery that chanamide
was a follower of the Obscure serpent
goddess yut shayez Ramadan is Keen to
find out more about the other priest
from chanamid's tomb
today is going to be a very interesting
day because our attention turns to the
second sarcophagus in the burial chamber
that we've been working in and now it's
the time to learn more about
he is hoping that a closer inspection of
yikut's casket might reveal why the two
priests share the same tomb
[Music]
the sarcophagus if you put stands out in
this complex because it is the only
anthropoid circumference a human form
sarcophagus and he could see the fingers
print of the person who applied this
mortar in the process of sealing the lid
deployed sarcophagi were intended to
portray an ideal of Egyptian beauty
and on ye puts Ramadan spots an
intriguing detail
interestingly they could see the face
here
that very
triangle-shaped nose this very pointed
very sharp nose and that very thin lips
it is not an Egyptian official features
it looks to me like possibly a foreign
person
and these sarcophagus is inscribed
giving us the name of the person who is
buried inside you put
that's very interesting because it
doesn't sound like an Egyptian name it
does sound a foreign name particularly
Libyan name something similar to what
we've seen with China mid
[Music]
if Ramadan is right and both China meat
and ye quote were of Libyan descent then
could that explain why they share the
same too
remarkably the links don't stop there
because the inscriptions on yiput's
sarcophagus also reveal the gods whom he
served and they include a now familiar
name
on the foot of ye put's casket is The
Telltale symbol of a serpent
[Music]
same goddess
Ramadan saw on chanamid sarcophagus and
the coffin of the priest with the silver
mask
therefore strong similarities in
connections between these two persons
one is both of them were priests second
they serve the same goddess new chess
third both of them possibly libyans
possibly Libyan immigrants who settled
in Egypt foreign
[Music]
in the search for more evidence the
team's next step is to look inside ye
put sarcophagus
[Music]
we are in a very tight space
then we have to move this human-sized
lid
right now I think they have to maneuver
turn around and make sure nothing Falls
inside the sarcophagus that would have
damaged The Mummy
[Music]
there you go
foreign
takes a quick look inside you put
sarcophagus
[Music]
beautiful
what we have here is a mummy similar to
China meets Mommy
similar mummification technique for the
two of them
there's very interesting we see a lot of
beads at the feet of this mummy
looks like they were put around the
mummy not really threaded and this is
something that I haven't seen before
[Music]
so we need to look closely to the face
and the body of airport
foreign
[Music]
hello
myself
finally for the first time in 2600 years
he puts money is fully revealed
that beautifully wrapped mummy coated
with this black Richmond
[Music]
you could see the old bandaged here the
mummy wrappings right here
looking closer Ramadan tries to make
sense of the shape of the body Beneath
The Mummy wrappings
he spies something totally unexpected
there is something quite mind-blowing
looking at the circumference of input
and the text
and his name that is written right here
and title being a priest of newches all
speaks to me as a man but now looking at
The Mummy I'm seeing something different
could see a silhouette of that left arm
over the chest
and then another protrusion here
possibly the right shoulder
going all the way down along the body so
what we have here is the left arm
um crossed over the chest while the
right arm extended along the body of
possibly reaching the pelvic area
this is the position that is restricted
to women of high status
in other words what the arm position
suggests is that instead of being a
priest of new chayez I put May in fact
have been a priestess
all these months I'm talking about ipunt
as a man and all of a sudden I have a
mummy with a hand and arm position that
is for a woman
I might belong but I would be very
surprised if there is no more surprises
in this complex
now we need to have this question
answered and the identification of the
sex of this mummy confirmed by x-ray
[Music]
after the shock discovery that the
priest ye put May in fact be a woman
Ramadan is Keen to reinvestigate the sex
of another of the priests from the
complex the priest with the Gilded
silver mask
[Music]
you're thinking it's male yeah but now
we might have a very big surprise in
terms of the sex of this mummy
laughs
now that the painted wooden coffin has
been removed
project consultant salima is able to
identify a crucial Tell-Tale feature
I mean certainly I can see from the brow
it's quite sharp that's certainly a
female trades were quite extraordinary
just as revealing is the mummy's crossed
arm position
when you have one arm crossed over your
breast and one along your side that pose
is something that is only seen with
female mummies and so the fact that this
body has the same pose would really
argue in addition to all of the physical
characteristics of the skeleton that
this is a woman
this is a surprise
the potential discovery of a second
Priestess is a fascinating development
having priestesses buried here is
significant because it tells us what
ancient Egyptian women were like in what
their social status was they have the
same social economic class they had the
same level of wealth the same level of
prestige and privilege and really it
emphasizes the point that in ancient
Egypt more than any other ancient
culture women had many more rights and
were far more equal to men than
elsewhere
yeah
sure the priest's sex though what
Ramadan needs is hard evidence
[Music]
so he's arranged for the mummies to be
x-rayed
starting with the priest chanamate
it's completely decayed so I'm trying to
lift the mummy
one beast but I think it's very hot
held together by a protective gauze it
means
The Fragile mummy is carefully lifted
out
good work
we get the mommy one piece
[Laughter]
remains are delicate to be hoisted to
the surface the team has created an
x-ray lab Underground
so we can make quick x-ray
radiologist Professor Sahar Saleem will
x-ray The Mummy in stages uh okay clear
please
starting with the head
okay shoot wow
unfortunately this doesn't look good
it's disappointing news
this doesn't look good at all
the the skull is so crumbled
Chana meets skull is too damaged to
glean any information from it
unfortunately I cannot tell whether this
is a man or woman
will go to the other Clues to determine
the sex I'm counting now on the pelvis
female pelvises are usually wider and
rounder than males
should
making them a reliable indicator of sex
um it was bad news
unfortunately because it's totally
destroyed
you cannot see any recognizable part of
the hip
unable to tell China meets sex the team
switches to ye put
the priest with the male name
but the female looking mummy
yipput is a mummy that kept me thinking
all the time the name is for a man the
title is for a priest but we're still
really not sure whether you put is a man
or woman
[Music]
a hundred feet beneath the desert inside
a makeshift lab
radiologist Sahar Salim is getting ready
to x-ray the two and a half
thousand-year-old mummy of ye put the
priest
prayer please she's hoping the scans
will confirm whether you put skeleton is
male or female
I'll do my best
I feel responsible for making everybody
happy
[Music]
the first thing to check is the arm
position
when we open the sarcophagus of your
food the Ramadan was suspicious about
the position of the arm
now we are going to x-ray this mummy and
figure out the real position of the arm
[Music]
okay ready
shoot
the first x-rays confirmed the team's
initial suspicions
okay good
the crossing of the left arm over the
chest it looks like the burial of a
woman it is very clear
further scans reveal other specific
Clues shoot
this skull is not really in a good
condition but this bone beneath the the
ear it is smooth and the roundness of
the skull I have this feeling that this
could be a woman
foreign
the pelvis also it is not that intact
but there is a big ground cavity just
towards a female also the blades of the
iliac region there are more flat this is
also with a woman
[Music]
the X-ray is telling me that you put is
a woman not a man
my journey in understanding what you put
is like a roller coaster of
understanding you go up one point and
then all of a sudden you drop down
this is what makes archeology so
interesting
and while there's no evidence to suggest
that China meat was a woman what the
team can be sure of is that the two
priests yiput and Chana meet shared a
similar status and background
[Music]
this chamber presented us with job with
information in the form of two beautiful
sarcophagi inscribed for two persons
their names Alone says something about
them being libyans immigrants who lived
in Egypt and become completely
egyptianized
[Music]
even more significant is the goddess
these two libyans along with the
Priestess and the silver mask worshiped
[Music]
track K24 has the largest number of
mentions of the goddess nuches in one
place in the entire country of Egypt
I think we discovered a new cult in
ancient Egypt The Cult of a goddess we
didn't know much about with priests and
priestesses who served her
[Music]
and to Ramadan a new cult suggests
something more
just have her own trying in the
immediate vicinity of Shaft k-24 or a
temple with economic revenues that
allows the priesthood to amass such
wealth that is reflected in the richness
of their burials
[Music]
questions like this that are the reason
why the team is still digging
and if the discovery is so far or
anything to go by then there will surely
be more secrets to uncover
the only reason to do egyptology is
because you enjoy it and love it you
love the ancient Egyptians you really
want to find out what they were doing
what they were thinking how they were
functioning it is also lovely because
you realize they might have lived three
thousand two thousand years ago but
there's very little difference between
them and us
[Music]
that were Mission here what we're doing
is looking for information and rewriting
the story of every individual we
discover here and we're still going to
gather more of that this is for us a
lifelong research project
[Music]